[Music]
some Christmas movies are sweet some are
funny others are just super super weird
but only one of them is all of those
things bye buddy hope you find your dad
thanks mr. Narwhal elf
meet buddy and orphan abandoned by his
mom after a one-night stand who's stolen
by Santa raised by a family who thinks
he's a burden and gets sent to New York
with nothing but the clothes on his back
to find his real dad who thinks he's
mentally ill and wants nothing to do
with him I love you I love you
I love ya that's weird huh when you laid
out like that it kind of sounds like a
Joker movie you want to know how I got
these tights enjoy a Will Ferrell
performance for the ages showing off his
infectious joy I just like to smile
smiling's my favorite
his physical comedy
and his deep gratitude that Jim Carrey
turned down this role and did the Grinch
instead as he gives a performance so
balls to the wall in saying you won't
even care that Zooey Deschanel hooks up
with someone who's mentally a child
or that Santa is real and no one seems
to care your shadows right or that bunny
has about three years left until the
diabetes takes him experience the most
honest portrayal of Christmas and Phil
where the holiday is all about printing
as much food into your mouth as you can
getting too drunk at work fighting with
your family and hoarding toys made
overseas in horrible working conditions
but most of all it's about having faith
in a higher power
you know the bearded guy come up above
so revisit the holiday classic from the
SNL guy who'd go from this to anchorman
the swingers guy who'd go from this to
Iron Man and the station agent guy who
go from this to Game of Thrones because
everyone in it is talented and deserves
the best in life what did you think I
was just gonna savage elf this movie is
delightful I'm not a monster
starring Elrond Burgundy Bob the Builder
a Manic Pixie dream girl christmas is
coming sidekicks Jeff Bezos and sent his
slaves a Christmas Ferrell you sure it
had nothing to do with the fact that I
was naked in the shower
I didn't know you're naked yeah I'm
calling shenanigans on that one buddy
this call will be recorded for quality
and training purposes
who killed off the dinosaurs I did plus
ultra my ear us bigger than this pen the
watermelon is a sue